lebron james has hit yet another
milestone this time doing something no
other nba player has ever done
after another monster year of earnings
totaling
121.2 million dollars last year forbes
estimates that james has officially
become a billionaire
the 37 year old superstar has a net
worth of 1 billion dollars by forbes
count
james who's missing the playoffs for
just the fourth time in 19 seasons is
the first active nba player to make the
billionaires list
michael jordan the only other basketball
billionaire didn't hit 10 figures until
2014 more than a decade after he retired
thanks to a well-timed investment in the
charlotte hornets basketball team
james has maximized his business with
more than 1.2 billion dollars in pre-tax
earnings
he has commanded more than 385 million
dollars in salary from the cleveland
cavaliers miami heat and los angeles
lakers as the nba's highest paid active
player
off the court he has raked in upwards of
900 million dollars in income from
endorsements and other business ventures
born in akron ohio james lived with an
assortment of family members friends
neighbors and his peewee football coach
moving a dozen times in three years
before becoming the most hyped high
school basketball prospect of all time
he inked his first deal with nike in
2003 at age 18
famously rejecting offers from reebok
and adidas in favor of what he saw as
the better long-term partner
after more than a decade of success he
struck a lifetime agreement with nike in
late 2015 that pays him tens of millions
annually
last year thanks to nike plus deals with
brands like a t
pepsico
and walmart he was the second highest
earning athlete in the world
but the real key to james's billion
dollar fortune he's been more than just
a pitch man
james has long structured deals to give
him equity and brands he partners with
giving him a cut of the upside instead
of a quick paycheck
in 2015 james walked away from an
endorsement agreement with mcdonald's
worth an estimated 15 million dollars
over four years to instead gamble on the
fast-growing blaze pizza chain where
he's an investor
he's taken equity in brands like smart
gym maker tonal and rideshare giant lift
as well
then there's spring hill the tv and
movie production outfit built by james
and business partner maverick carter
last october outside investors bought
into the venture which helped produce
the 163 million dollar space jam a new
legacy an hbo documentary what's my name
muhammad ali at a 725 million dollar
valuation
james of course remains the biggest
shareholder
james has publicly dreamed about one day
owning an nba team and he's well on his
way the basketball star already counts
pro baseball
soccer and hockey teams among his
holdings
but his fortune wouldn't be complete
without his real estate holdings
he owns at least three properties worth
about 80 million dollars in all he built
a 10 million dollar mansion near his
hometown of akron ohio and he bought an
eight bedroom property in la for 23
million dollars
his latest splurge a 13 000 square foot
beverly hills mansion james paid
36.75 million dollars for the home which
he has already torn down to replace with
a mansion of his own
[Music]
you